time for today's bad shot it's this
Greece's key indicator of stress this is
a charge showing Greek bank deposits how
much money essentially is on deposit
with banks in the country being between
September 2009 that's the green circle
and jun 2012 that's the red circle Greek
depositors withdrew thirty-seven percent
of their cash from local banks what
crucial is that most of this money as
you can see from jun 2012 that fled the
banking system never actually came back
in at the low in june 2012 total cash in
the banking system was down to about 150
1 billion euros by the end of november
2014 the far right of your screen it had
increased 12 billion euros to 164
billion that's still 74 billion euros
below the peak of 238 billion in
September 2009 now as my colleague mark
Gilbert wrote on bloomberg view on
December the 31st this suggests saver
still aren't convinced their money is
safe so a key measure to watch in coming
months as the Greek government of course
tries to come up with some sort of deal
with the troika is whether the banking
system starts to bleed deposits again
and we do know since the end of 2014
because this chart ends on November 2014
we've had further data showing the
outflow of deposits once again started
to drop in December falling a further
three billion euros this drop by the way
continued into January another worrying
signal has been that Greek lenders have
been borrowing from the nation's central
bank emergency line that's a sign that
some banks could be struggling to fund
their activities amid an outflow of
deposit to do keep an eye on this chart
to ascertain what really is happening on
the ground in Greece and how the
population are reacting is this Greece's
key indicator of stress